I went up for tublat about the first
time for a meeting in 2003 there's quite
a while ago now and I was there
representing this group called BTS women
the British Computer Society women's
group so I was going up there
representing them and I didn't really
know much about Bletchley Park on the
way there in my head I kind of thought
maybe it was like 50 old blokes kind of
wearing tweed jackets smoking pipes and
doing The Times crossword on the side
and maybe a bit of code breaking so that
was kind of my idea and I think in those
days everyone kind of thought that's
that's what went on there
first trip that more than 10,000 people
worked there which was a shock and that
more than half them were women and being
a woman in computing I was really
interested in that so ran an oral
history project after that to capture
the memories of the women that worked
there
HMS Pembroke five was just an umbrella
word to cover the activities that took
place at Bletchley Park and so the
launch of that I actually found out that
Bletchley Park were having financial
difficulties so that's the first time
I'd been aware of that and then I was up
at a reception just after that at
Bletchley Park and that's actually the
first time I did a proper tour of the
whole site that's when I saw that you
know the hearts that looked like they
were falling down you know I was like
Hut six with a blue tarpaulin over it
and had a proper tour with someone who'd
who'd worked there during the Second
World War and you know he was telling us
about all the major code-breaking
achievements in each of the hearts and
and I just thought well and this place
might close you know it was said that
the work that was done there shortened
the war by approximately two years
eleven million people a year were dying
and I just thought it's ridiculous now
you know we've got to do something about
it you're a computer scientist by trade
well I suppose it's all kind of geeky
and techie I'm gonna definitely I'm a
geek and you know I've got a degree in
computing and a PhD in software
engineering so I guess I really am a
geek right and so there's a very strong
connection with it kind of all that the
maths to start with you know there's
loads of mass in computing and the mass
in sort of cryptography and stuff so you
know I loved it from from the geeky
aspect but also the you know the human
point of view and the fact that all
these people work there so I kind of had
both for me really and and of course the
fact that it was about 8,000 women and
and young women as well so I didn't find
that out till later but they were mainly
like between 18 and 23 the women so you
know thousands of young women you know
and some young men and a few old men all
together you know doing this code
breaking and you know and kind of trying
to save millions of lives it's just an
incredible story by the time it got to
2008 which when I started the campaign I
was head of department at University of
Westminster so I was head over
science department and you know I found
out that Bletchley Park might have to
close because they didn't have enough
money and I just thought I've got to do
something about this so I emailed all
the other heads and professors of
computing in the country and asked them
to sign a petition which was on the
government website at the time and and
in those days you could look at the
names of the people that were signing so
you know I sent this email out and then
a few hours later I thought I'll see if
anyone signed it and I looked at the
petition there's all these famous
professors of computing from the UK and
I was like oh my goodness all these
professors you know think the same as me
we've got to do something about it that
really gave me confidence to then take
it further
so what we did was we wrote a letter to
the time so that was signed by ninety
seven heads and professors and also I
contacted all the journalists that I
knew which in those days was only about
four but luckily one of them was Rory
Kaplan Jones from the BBC he got back in
touch with me and then got me on BBC
news the next week and so July 2008 I
was on BBC news saying I'm ashamed to be
British we've got to save Bletchley Park
and that went across the world which was
amazing but then I noticed that you know
a few weeks later I just thought well
what can I do now because I've made a
big splash but like nothing much is
happening so it wasn't till a few months
after that that I started using Twitter
and social media and then realised quite
quickly the potential of using
particularly Twitter for kind of finding
people that are interested in the same
subject in creating a social media
campaign how'd it feel have you been
back since much I've probably been there
probably been to Bletchley Park
I don't know 50-100 times now but I have
to say every time I go I see something
different and find out something new so
it's a very exciting place to visit for
me you know even now and you know so
there's Bletchley Park on one slide
which is all the history and the
cryptography stuff and there's of course
the National Museum of computing which
is on site there - both equally amazing
attractions and yeah there's just so
much there to see I've you know I've
probably been back like I said about 50
times and you know there's all the code
breaking hearts there there's stuff
about the women that work there
there's the rebuild of Turing's bombe
machine which is incredible if you get a
chance to see that working at the Museum
of computing they've got Colossus
working you know just these amazing
machines which had to be rebuilt because
of course they were all destroyed at the
end of World War two so there's some
incredible attractions there and I think
the site is about 26 acres so you know
it's a really large site with something
for everyone so the campaign took about
three years so we started with
traditional media and social media about
six months in and it took about another
two and a half years after that for the
director of Bletchley Park to actually
say that Bletchley Park wasn't you know
wasn't ever going to close and that it
was safe because they got four point 1
million Heritage Lottery funding which
of course you know substantially helped
with the renovation so so the book is
the story I've written the story of the
campaign what we did using social media
so it's kind of a primer in in how to
use social media in a campaign too but
then that's also intercut with a story
of the women that work there of enigma
and cheering and you know all the things
that you've probably heard about would
like to know more about that that
stories in there too so what's next
anywhere
bring back any more British institutions
well I mean actually my focus now is
tech mums so you know the stuff that I'm
doing now which is all about teaching
mums to be more confident and to
understand technology so we've got a
program which is stuff like basic IT
skills through to app design and web
design social media staying safe online
and a bit of coding in pythons because I
love getting the mums having a go at
Python programming too and the programs
running in London Dublin Essex and and
now in Nottingham too here we are at
Bletchley Park but in a part of the
Bletchley Park site of this the National
Museum of computing in the UK and
they've had a sense to have the siting
here for the rebuild of the Colossus
machine